tickets for the in-person sin Week
events are available through the end of
January don't miss out on your chance to
join the sin crew and the sin club for
delicious food sinful movie watching and
more the live event is in Nashville this
March check the link in the video
description for all the details
[Music]
[Music]
previously on Rick and Morty previously
on before Rick and Morty committed the
Cardinal TV sin of having a previously
on in their episode I really don't know
where to go with this because let me
tell you Rick and Morty thinks they've
created the most TV sins proof episode
yet and I think they may be right they
may defeat me but I guess I could just
start sitting myself for liking raccoons
more than dogs or preferring eggs over
Pizza things are going to get really
weird over here for the next few minutes
so I guess I'll just leave you with
potato salad Jerry I had sex with your
wife not realizing Jerry would probably
be less mad about this and more turned
on by it or maybe I'm just projecting my
own fetishes onto this scenario because
what I've always found useful is working
out your demons with episodes of Rick
and Morty at least that's what Carl told
me who's Carl you might ask I'm just
getting to know him but if it helps he
does live in my left pinky I did it I
fixed portals travel show reminds me of
its lack of commitment to a portalis
existence I'm pregnant having the cake
on the table with the candles lit before
you finish the primary meal also
positioning the cake closer to the
camera than the birthday person it's
raining meatballs and you'd think I'd do
a simple quicksand here like cloudy with
a Chance of Rick and Morty but since I
don't give a shout about what you think
I'm just gonna send the fact that I've
never once seen a pickup basketball game
in this driveway and that basketball
goal honestly looks like it's never been
used and for the record I do care what
you think I Caro so much please don't
hate me thanks for solving that murder
guys here's a skateboard thinking that
solving a murder is anywhere near as
impressive as doing a kickflip say
you'll marry me what let's just say yes
being forced into marrying her
grandfather is a meta plot point or
really just at all I do it for our
honeymoon let's go to a steel
Chamberlain with a nice deuterium why
because the charge acts as a narrative
decelerant Morty none of this is real if
nothing here is real then how would an
isotope have an observable effect on the
fake matter in your fake reality unless
just saying it does the thing means it
does the thing but that would mean that
name dropping ionized Deuteronomy was an
extra step and Rick could have just said
let's go to a sealed chamber lined with
a narrative decelerant now repeat after
me Morty next time on Rick and Morty
next time on Rick and Morty no
previously on Rick and Morty preemptive
narration to counteract the subsequent
narration leads to my narration sending
your narration we gotta get through the
opening time titles oh [ __ ] me I didn't
want to have to do this but if the Rick
and Morty Riders are going to kick down
the walls of their reality and attempt
to make this episode unsinnable I really
have no choice but to prove to Medicine
versus that no episode is truly without
sin
even if that involves sitting myself I
am alive
no need to be so melodramatic sorry
decreasing dramatization by five percent
better make it 15. [ __ ] you perfect now
you just keep sending the video like
that and I think we might just get
through this city activate this in
transfer array
well also you adding a sin just because
you didn't like something is not really
an issue with the show magnificent let's
go oh my God don't squirrel I'm pretty
sure that's a sugar glider and not a
squirrel and I understand most people
don't know what a sugar glider is but
then just make it look like a [ __ ]
squirrel how hard could that be don't
succumb to his pointless self-aware
[ __ ] says the king of pointless
self-aware [ __ ] and that may be the
point but do you know what I have to say
to that potato salad he wriggled back to
the metal layer through a hole in the
fourth wall cemeta Antics aside adding a
convenient meta layer to your story to
essentially unmeta The Meta Story You've
created and acting like the encroachment
on my territory would go unchallenged
bro you literally just did the same
thing just because you have a sign that
says check out guns doesn't mean that we
can't send checkoff's guns because if we
don't send checkoff's guns then the sin
doesn't come into play and it becomes
chekhov's sins which doesn't even make
sense because who's to say where and
when a sin can have action in the end
maybe it's just chekhov's Rick and Morty
and maybe that's the point and maybe
nothing means anything and I mean
nothing and am I even really here all
you hear is a voice a voice that could
be coming from a computer a simulation
or a ghost all of this to say I want to
send checkoff's guns because they are my
guns to send damn it and you're not my
mother that being said I'd also like to
thank the writers for their cynicist
with these metaphorically literal
representations of narrative Concepts my
job is much easier when you lay them out
like this I mean it's funny when I do a
little nod to the viewers but viewers
Morty would be the most meta thing to
ever meta at medicines and if Rick and
Morty continues down this path we might
just create that channel to [ __ ] with
them personally none of this season
three Moonlighting talking about season
three of Moonlighting when we all know
that season 5 was the real problem [ __ ]
you a womb with a view I'll never get
that hour of my life back also nothing
the kids like like these days more than
Moonlighting jokes although we just made
a Moonlighting joke didn't we yes you
did damn it he needs to be put down like
a rabid dog literally breaking the
fourth wall running in the opposite
direction of Trials honestly don't know
if that's good or a bad thing but I've
got a job to do and just like this
episode appears to be doing out of pure
desperation I'm throwing a lot of stuff
at the wall and hoping a few things
stick is this whole place just a bunch
of grown-inducing wordplay for seven TV
critics that won't even enjoy it we're
not critics it's a comedy channel a
comedy channel also thinking wordplay is
more grown-inducing than Wordle man that
I don't enjoy both the narrator thinks
the writers of this show would honor him
with such a reference even though the
critical value of his commentaries as
questionable as his Wordle skills and
there aren't seven sins writers there's
one two three four five six and Jeremy
makes a whole week
that every second we spin here is the
equivalent to 10 Space Jam cameos
sending your own appearance in a
terrible movie does not exclude us from
sending your appearance in that terrible
movie and just in case our dad's in
Channel didn't send you the first time
around we're giving you two here I'm
here this deus ex machina riding in on
Leon's prayers like some kind of literal
literary Jesus cannot absolve you of
your TV sins
I have refusal of the call hey story
Lord's back and now I'm gonna send
myself for remembering who the [ __ ]
story Lord is but how could I not this
episode is a sequel to the first episode
I ever appeared in the video as your
narrator and three years later I still
get asked where the [ __ ] the other guy
went and when will he be back and it
doesn't hurt doesn't hurt at all not a
bit narrative thinks it's just because
he's taking the guardrails off the ride
he can then sends wherever he pleases
stay in your lane also it's not like
just because this is a sequel to the
episode where I appeared out of thin air
to start narrating that we'd go back to
the original narrator for this video
nope I'm out it's all you buddy you
think I want to deal with this plus
you've been killing it as the narrator
in fact you're so universally beloved
and supremely talented I'm wondering if
you should narrate Cinema Sins we have
to stop letting narrators write their
own scripts
sorry to keep interrupting but I do need
to mention that a shout out like this
used to remind me of the Glorious hours
I spent reading the Nightfall storyline
in the Batman comics and now just
reminds me of that [ __ ] Dark Knight
Rises movie that for some goddamn reason
a lot of you are still trying trying to
tell yourself is a good movie and it
really pisses me right the [ __ ] off
sorry carry on I'm the Jesus from every
Jesus joke which reminds me have you
heard this one who's the shortest man in
the Bible give up it's Nehemiah you get
it me high Maya
you don't be laughing if Svengoolie was
telling that joke
previously on Jesus Christ this
narration into flashback's position is
an automatic sensation now that's
grunt-inducing words like dude she's a
hooker the entire second season script
of White Lotus somehow makes it into the
episode
come on guys I can believe in Jesus or
the Loch Ness monster but not both
unless their Partners on the force who
initially hate working with each other
but then learn to mutually respect one
another by the end of their first murder
case make me normal witch this pantsless
Jesus is Five Seasons late to the rixie
business episode Leon you saved Our
Lives not only did he save your lives
but he saved your lives by Killing Jesus
is there a bigger sin than Killing Jesus
how many sins should I give oh of course
he met him Morty his life doesn't matter
yours does prick staring into the camera
there is by far the most unsubtle fourth
wall break I've ever seen this series do
but I manages to feel more meaningful
than all the others because it's
delivered with a sincerity that Rick
usually comes across as incapable of I'm
not gonna claim to completely understand
it but the writers took care not to bury
this message in a joke and telling
people they have value is a message I'd
like to help amplify as well the
narrator was being a bit of a
monologueist there but I agree with the
sentiment so I'll take a sin off as well
you want to know what happened like
specifically writers write a writer
deliver delivering Exposition about the
writer's written writing that was just
some nonsense to see how many times you
could put a variation in the word right
into a sentence okay here's your
motivation you're looking for motivation
you want all the motivation writers make
fun of the character motivation they
dreamed of because hating your own ideas
is the 20s versions of hating anything
your parents thought was cool the
narrator delivers a sin that's super
argumentative because he doesn't really
know what motivated the writers to write
the motivation motive they're meta nerds
that found out they could be less
bearable as a team TV staff anti-meta
field show has Rick create a theme using
technomagic thereby creating a
contradictory world that somehow has
enough rules to make science feasible
and enough creative license to make
literally anything else feasible don't
try it flashback come on flash Baxter
was right there it runs on hydrogen
Isotopes a few barrels of petroleum
should dampen it run Morty show is now
doing whatever it wants without regard
for anything and somehow the plot still
makes sense so I should probably remove
this in but instead I'm adding one Mary
here and for Addison's when you should
be removing them but I'm obliged to take
sides in this sin as part of some
broader narrative that will be explained
at some point maybe
whether it's not there before yes
there's been a Connie tenuity error
acting as if continuity errors are a
part of Storytelling may as well include
typo Mary and Karma splice but the way
Rick and Morty's bodies and clothes heal
they may have a point that's pretty
that's
protagonist
why would Rick tell Morty to duck
they're already the protagonist of the
story and since Rick knows he's in a TV
show shouldn't he know that and knowing
that shouldn't protago Nick's Powers be
useless against Rick and Morty come on
protag Ernest was right there vignetting
in a wacky episode like this is if we're
about to finally get the
interdimensional streaming episode we've
been waiting for no one's been waiting
for this because no one ever knows when
Rick and Morty episodes will be
available for streaming they really went
all in on Nessie and these different
continuities didn't they Nessie is
quickly becoming the David S pumpkins of
Rick and Morty or at least we can help
or do we not want that to happen can we
flash back to what I was saying the
other day
foreign
damn it they got him in a Cell made out
of sports because it's the opposite of
story tell that to the producers of
drive to survive but his name is Brett
Khan I think Brett's a name too his name
could be retcon naming a character Brett
Khan for no other reason than getting in
your retcon joke and just so you know if
you named him retcon to begin with I
would have sent you for not naming him
bretcon for those of you who are new to
the channel welcome to TV since narrator
doesn't I've painted the show into a
corner just to deliver my welcome to TV
since cliche what is my purpose to wait
until I tell you to pull the lever
retconning butter robot to have never
passed the butter you monster explaining
the show's callbacks because you think
we'll make people like you also that one
hurt cool quiet you I'm in control now
if you don't free me right now Rick I
can make very very bad things always
have been the case for you if we're at
the human mankind can affect Rick's
story while he's in this cage why would
he make very bad things have always been
the case instead of just making Rick
have always opened the door and this
Fortress has always been an orange and
it has always been in a fruit bowl which
has always been on the top shelf right
right oh come on the narrator's need for
acknowledgment is consuming him oh it
hurts Joe severely under explains how
Rick and Morty got from the orange that
just became all of existence to this
frozen tundra what happened you atoned
since when is nearly dying in a
snowstorm the same as atoning if that
were the case Buffalo would be the most
virtuous place in the world and it's not
that's where Josh lives he knows what he
did the narrator and I would likely have
a better grasp of what is going on if we
read more books and watch less TV I'm
Joseph Campbell making me think of Heart
of Darkness even though you're Joseph
Campbell who I often get confused with
Joseph Conrad but regardless it makes me
think of Heart of Darkness and I hate
thinking about Heart of Darkness why is
that prick here no more a prick than you
friend the animated representation of
Joseph Campbell would be some [ __ ] on
a hero's journey at TV sins TV since guy
would be excellent at letting other
people do his job storing Joseph
Campbell in the personification of all
that is in the unconscious I'm pregnant
what are you doing
bearded Rick thinks Joseph Campbell
impregnated a bearded Morty so he tries
to drown him in a bucket of water improv
the rest is how I imagine the scene was
written no that's just an excuse for you
to verbally describe what is happening
on screen because for some reason you
think it's funny to do so I hope this
version skips Ember and dry blood trying
to be creative instead of just saying
discount Song of Ice and Fire when you
get home Rick do some classic Adventures
like season one so sick of that [ __ ]
note what the [ __ ] does even mean
of all the fourth wall breaking jokes
this show has done that one is my
favorite
cubicles one of the writers has a job
with cubicle one time and now they make
the same Tire joke every time a roof
then pops up on screen you know what
I've had enough of you
let's never do that again wait you have
to register the real joke isn't that
this alien is too unmotivated to
register to look at porn it's that he's
going to a site where you have to
register for porn he's bad at porn I
don't take notes Rick and Morty writers
constantly reminding us they don't care
about feedback while constantly making
episodes directly related to said
feedback kid I'm a writer that wrote
something successful did you you wrote a
character so shallow that he literally
has no motivation but you did manage to
help build a machine capable of sucking
motivation from beings all across the
universe so I think you missed your
calling there you failed me storylord is
not only still alive but still able to
talk after being inflicted with a
massive head wound Harry look if you're
gonna make weird and dated references
Rick and Morty then I'm gonna make weird
and dated references it's my right and
at least I'd never stooped having Joseph
[ __ ] Campbell in my story mainly
because I don't I don't know who Joseph
Campbell is Joseph Campbell also says
you have to use this brand new limited
edition Rick plush available only on
Rick Dash plush.biz not a real product
or website that I had to waste time
researching and that is frankly a
terrible urls
potato salad
[Music]
do me a favor throw that down the toilet
thanks for solving that murder guys not
many people know I love swamp ass
[Music]
oh yeah no you don't want to wear those
over here things that could have been
brought to my attention yesterday
his name is story Lord what kind of
stupid name is that I'm your worst
nightmare
if I suck at your blood I'll beep
[Music]
to chew bubblegum and kick ass no more a
prick the new friend well I'd like to
take a moment to review the separate
ways in which you're a douchebag